[Music]
welcome back to Hannity and here is the
final part of our exclusive interview
with Rush Limbaugh you're a student of
history you're a student of politics you
live eat and breathe this have you ever
seen deep state leaks about one a day
the Democrats hate the president
Republicans are weak and many of them as
you point out I think they want him to
fail you got this never Trump or crowd
and then the media all aligned against
them ever seen at this pad never never
have people say that Nixon was the
object of hatred and derision and he was
but I have never seen Trump is really
exposing the people that do run or think
they run this country and they are
scared to death and they're angry they
feel betrayed by the election and what
they're demonstrating is they are
perfectly willing perfectly willing to
get rid of Trump any way they can and
overturn the results of an election
simply because they don't like it when
the Muller investigation is it's a
prelude to finding a crime or a
misdemeanor that might be impeach evil
or creating a process run you know I
give a funny about the Muller
investigation what I hear they can't
find a crime there wasn't a crime to
start with us there should have been
what they're finding the Democrat side
they're trying to sweep aside Hillary a
rigged primary against crazy Bernie that
would never forget folks Trump runs the
Department of Justice right now so
nothing is over until Trump does
something with it so chin up about that
I've never seen look at the powerful
tools of intelligence which we need to
keep the country safe then you got
surveillance you got a mass key you
don't have minimization then look at the
case of general Flynn leaking
intelligence a violation of the
Espionage Act a Likud day the president
has right that I I've never seen that in
my life
no but what happens when Liv
everything's been politicized the
intelligence politicize no matter what
they want to tell us there's not a thing
that the left doesn't try to take
control of our influence that does not
become politicized
when that happens it becomes corrupted
liberalism corrupts and the intelligence
community look at what they're doing
they're actually now using whatever
making things up like the Trump dha'fi
whatever they can do to force the
president out of office or to dwindle
support among his voters and supporters
and I just I just think it's corruption
on display and most of it is coming from
big government liberal types but beyond
it also the establishment itself I know
that's a word that's thrown around but
it is the people that run the country
and it is you don't know them we don't
know who the leader is
they're not elect the elected members
are part of it but they're not the
powerbase the elected people are told
what to do they're given the money and
the donations and so forth it's all this
is being exposed I think you said about
the President's speech at the UN never
before has anybody ever spoken this way
to the UN it's never happened by an
American president you got North Korea I
think a real threat this guy's nuts
you got Iran the Iranian deal will
probably be there in five or ten years
dealer have the same issues of a you
know radical mullahs armed with nuclear
weapons and ICBMs peace through strength
you believe it I believe it how do you
view is foreign policy I think the
foreign policy is like everything most
everything else he's doing I like it
because it's unique it's different and
it's common sensical I laughed myself
silly it's on news story that this
little pot-bellied dictator Kim jong-il
is so confused
yeah by what Trump saying that he's
calling a publicans in Washington to
help them understand what's Trump saying
you keep it up and you're not going to
exist you keep it up and you're gonna
regret it
this guy calls what does he mean what
does he mean and the people is calling
don't know now to analyze Trump either
Trump is a foreign object to these
people politics is in in one way so
phony it's it's the art of not saying
what you really mean Trump comes along
says what he means and then doubles down
on it and that's why people around the
country are cheering and standing up he
talks the way they do
diplo speak or political speak and he
just gets in gets it and gets out and
all of that is intimidating I think and
all of it because it upsets the natural
order things the way politics is talked
about in community and foreign policy
especially I love it when I think about
all these people State Department Trump
says to the North Korean guy you keep it
up and you don't exist this is the way
people talk to each other and the guy
apparently has gotten the message if
he's calling here trying to figure out
what Trump means that means he's got the
message of yet does he really mean what
yes he does in this case I think I think
he does I've work in the media and I
honestly feel at least on cable TV I'm
like an island unto myself right now we
have me and some of my colleagues at Fox
radio you're more popular than ever with
all the means and devices people who
listen to now you watch media you you've
turned over to CNN you've turned over to
MSNBC the president has taken them on
and I watch it and it's rush they never
talk about the Forgotten men and women
and people in poverty on food stamps
that need jobs what the election in my
but mine was about it's Russia Russia
Russia conspiracies outright lies
calling the president alight if you said
on your radio show half of what is said
daily about then President Obama the
whole left-wing in the country would
have tried to fire you right and it
would have been front page above the
fold for a week to leap years that you
know it's a good point the media isn't
mediate and what do you give me do you
think of media there got people out
there looking at things where you're not
and they tell you what happened that's
the news they don't do the news there is
no news there is the advancement of a
Democrat Party agenda the witches get
rid of Trump they're totally devoted to
it the meeting has been corrupt and by
liberalism Sean I don't watch CNN MSNBC
used to for show prep I've banned all
content from MSNBC on my show why
promote that garbage it just makes me
mad I don't watch it my life is
actually mood wise attitude wise huge
increase for the better by turning off
left-wing so-called news at night I
decided to pay people to come on at 9:00
now I hope you're watching case turn on
Fox that's it that's the point but there
is there not news their media their
agents of and not just a Democrat Party
I think the media is the force and the
power of the left and the Democrat Party
is an arm of it now the media is running
the agenda and promoting it but my last
question you're gonna hate this question
so I'm giving you the heads up you don't
like this question your TV show is a big
hit when you come on TV people want to
hear from you
you have the highest rated nationally
syndicated radio show in the country
huge audiences without people can listen
all sorts of ways I think people would
like to see you on TV maybe an hour a
week I do ever see I told you you'd hate
it
there's something going on everybody is
telling you I got a couple callers this
week now did they call you and you tell
them to call me no other people here is
an emissary for Fox you need to be on TV
one hour a week one hour one maybe two
well I'll give you the short answer I've
been totally satisfied with radio I I'm
so blessed I can't like every day pinch
myself over the great things the
American people have made possible for
me by being in the audience my TV show
was collaborate I don't collaborate I
don't know how you do your radio show
but I never have one meeting I'd have to
tell anybody when Uncas zero beforehand
television you have to have three hours
of meetings for a 22-minute show and put
everything in order floor managers - I
can't we just changed I don't have
meetings I have one phone call that
lasts 20 minutes that's it and what
happens in that phone call you tell them
what you're going to do in order or do
they tell you what they want you to know
we'll all due respect to my producers
I'm telling them what we're going okay
and we have to stick with it once it's
nerve we change it up to the last second
you've got improbable oh absolutely
well
absolutely is that all is that a sign of
hope well I told you you wouldn't like
the question but I know I do know you
I think people would love it that's you
flatter me you really appreciate that
very much
yeah well listen I know you don't do a
lot of interviews thank you for being on
no I love your success the country's
learned a lot from you over the years
and as as a radio guy you paved the path
I have not had as many slings and arrows
because you paved a pretty wide path and
you ought to take all of those early on
I remember when you went out there I
remember the Pat Sajak filling yeah I
remember thank the audience you got hit
hard and you never stopped and you kept
pushing through and it's made it easier
for guys like me thank you very much but
it's grown it's amazing how it's grown
that's wife we're winning everywhere
except in Washington we're winning the
Democrats can't win an election I know
they're losing elections they've lost
over a thousand seats this is so so
frustrating we got an opportunity that
we're never gonna have me months all it
would take
that's all it would take three months
past the agenda McConnell's the worst
rush
he can't how do you how do you not get
50 votes on health care after seven and
a half years you got to find out who
actually influences him that doesn't
want them
[Music]